it says uh dear Joe it's good to be
working with you again Martin Scorsese
that was my Martin's curse as invitation
what's up everybody this is Joseph
Sakura and this is gq's 10 things that I
cannot live without
[Music]
look at the color of my skin I'm
translucent sunscreen is very important
to me because like I always say I come
in the colors of the Polish flag white
and red I got one here for my rosacea I
got my New York favorite kiehls another
like Fancy Pants one that my wife has me
wear every now and again full body arms
everywhere but giving my SPF to make
sure they're on my face I wear them rain
or shine summer or winter I gotta have
sunscreen on at all times
[Music]
my next essential item is
a yoga mat I try to take one everywhere
I go it's just nice to have this I was
doing a movie with Dion Taylor called
fear that you should go check out and I
was doing jump squats in a hit class and
I broke my kneecap because I was doing
it on concrete and stone floor so now I
wisely after I healed bring my yoga mat
everywhere that I can because you need a
little bit of cushioning I love to do
yoga but I also love hit classes and I
have found you don't need a whole lot of
weight to get results you just need to
not eat as much as I want to and be
consistent
[Music]
people say you know Eat to Live don't
live tea I live to eat I don't care and
one of those items is jardner especially
hot Gardener now the GQ team is talented
and as wonderful as they are this is not
Chicago authentic jardner it might do in
a pinch I gotta tell you I put it on
everything put it on pasta I put on
pizza anything even slightly Italian I
put it on sandwiches I love an Italian
hero of course you have to put it on
Italian beef and I get my beef dip
that's kind of this wonderful Mash of
and uh jardner with the spicy oil and
made my mouth water just now let's check
it out I'm not I'm not opposed to
licking my fingers either we got a good
piece of cauliflower here too
cauliflower is good it's heavy on the um
on the pickling on the vinegar which you
don't want to be overpowered by the
vinegar this is super not Chicago that
it's super watery here and Chicago to
just be pure oil this ain't hitting
right but it's a decent try um this is
mild I'm already nervous oh my God no
oil just in water
bizarrely it's almost better because
without this spice it's like it's a
different animal pickled vegetable but
it's just um there's kind of a freshness
as you can tell there's a crunch to it
I'm going to give it a salad too and say
peace
okay for my next essential it's a bit of
a surprise it's actually a beautiful
hero sandwich for you no it is a very
special and dear thing to me from my
good friend the drama King the street
sweeper DJ casely he made this for me
with my graffiti name on it he put Dez
TMT which is a huge honor growing up
being a graffiti writer having that be
so much a part of my identity part of
the reality of my Urban experience Des
one is one of the prominent Graffiti
Writers of all time in history this is a
beautiful reminder of meeting one of
your Heroes and this is super special to
me I can't believe I'm getting choked up
I'm a little embarrassed he gave me a
lot of belief in myself and my claim
that maybe rap is something you do but
hip-hop is something you live my
playlist I'm all over the place but I'm
I love that Golden Era of hip-hop you
know Rakim is always on my my top five
Big L and Jr the damager and Big Daddy
Kane and I love still love Kumo D and I
love the war between Kumo D and LL and
you know it was kind of that Golden Era
of hip-hop that brought the brands like
you know Brand Nubian and uh jungle
brothers and tribe and just this
wonderfully inclusive era of hip-hop
that was respectful of everybody in some
capacity and it was about knowledge and
progression it felt good
[Music]
next essential item that I can't live
without it's my money clip money grip a
money clip is so much better than a
wallet for me because it's just you pop
it out you got all your bills here can't
go nowhere without a hundo this will buy
me a coffee and a sandwich in New York I
have a funny little Visa card that you
can get clothes on that my mother-in-law
gave me and I think it's got 50 bucks on
here and I still haven't spent it I'm
kind of a cash guy and then I have my
Chicago Ventra card it's the Chicago
version of this this is for the the L
train the CTA I didn't have these
forever because I was against them one
of my favorite possessions is my metro
card how do you get anywhere in New York
without a metro card when people are too
bougie to have a metro card I'm sorry
for you sitting in traffic and breathing
in those fumes when you be surrounded by
wonderful New Yorkers in a sea of
humanity and get wherever you need to go
in all of the five boroughs I like
tangible stuff
this lion the Leo this is one of my
essentials because it was a really
difficult time in my life I had recently
gotten stage fright here in New York on
Broadway and then I ended up doing a
play at Chicago Shakespeare cymbaline
Sean cross who played Imogen the lead in
the play and I played her Star-Crossed
lover posthumous Leonidas which
obviously Leonidas meaning the lion she
gave me this afterwards and it was a
long journey for both of us she's one of
the country's Premier Shakespearean
actresses Sean cross and I'm not she
gave me this afterwards because we
really came far in our friendship and
going through a Shakespeare play The
Bard's words are pretty difficult a lot
of the time and it was really an
accomplishment and the beginning to
getting over my stage fright which took
me about 10 years to get over and I'm
still getting over it I still have stage
fright but it was during the power show
where I felt the freedom again to play
and not to be quite distressed and have
fun in the moment and I'm eternally
grateful for that and this reminds me
that I'm eternally grateful and I can
conquer my fears a big bad lion ah
foreign
my next essential is a thank you card
from a very special director named
Martin Scorsese this is when I was doing
Boardwalk Empire I had just done a tiny
little role in Shutter Island and then I
got casting Boardwalk Empire and it's
also very special because on the same
day that I got this thank you card from
Martin Scorsese is the exact same day
when I first met
the woman who would become my wife so
very special it took me a long time I've
been acting 37 years because I was not
successful but consistently acting
mainly doing Theater in Chicago I never
really claimed being an actor it wasn't
until probably about 15 years ago that I
felt like you know I'm an actor and a
certain sense of of coming into my own
being the person that I was becoming and
owning it and Marty was incredible you
know I'm in Chicago and I'm too humble
I'm just happy to be here and stuff and
he's like no no you're here for a reason
stand up be proud put your chest out
what do you got there in the notebook
and I'm like oh I just wrote the
backstory for this character he goes
read me the whole thing so I ended up
reading Martin Scorsese three full
single line College ruled pages of my
backstory of my character it made me
feel really good and important and I'm
grateful super grateful to him and it's
kind of a that was kind of really a
starting point for
the rest of my career it says uh dear
Joe it's good to be working with you
again my name's Chris Easy that was my
Martin Scorsese invitation
[Music]
my next essential is the dog tags it
says James Barr which is the character
that I played in the Jack Reacher movie
Tom Cruise's Jack Reacher movie why are
these so important to me it was more
than just the character but it was the
relationship obviously I love Tom Cruise
I love to work with Tom again he's a
constant professional I can't say enough
nice things about Tom Cruise a super
nice guy always remembered my name
consummate professional and demanded
that you bring your A game and for all
of those things but I met one of my best
friends Jai Courtney I'm so grateful for
the friends that I've made in the
entertainment industry uh other actors
because it's I think it's harder than
you think there's such a weirdness in
this business competitiveness
judgmentalness jadedness so when you
find the good ones you want to keep them
close to play a pretty backwards awful
murderer James Barr and to walk away
with so many positive things is no small
feet
[Music]
not a lot I kept the bullet that Tommy
used the blank to kill Angela but it is
fun to look at I'm just like oh look at
this this is the one that is the one
that got her
[Music]
step on this journey art from the Sakura
family the first option I'm going to
show you it's a charcoal drawing that my
little niece did and I think she was six
years old when she did this and my wife
and I were just blown away Arwen you are
an incredible artist don't ever stop and
I have no idea what this means and I'm
wondering if it you know a six-year-old
or maybe she was eight but no older than
that knew what necessarily this means
either but it's like such a wonderful
reason to make art it's just to express
something I think everybody sees is love
and unity and Oneness part two is my
mom's painting of a sunset in New
Buffalo Michigan isn't that unbelievable
like every time I look at it I feel like
it's a window and I'm actually watching
the sunset my third thing is this box
that my brother made for me for
Christmas and I don't know which
Christmas you probably can't see but
there's a little Santa Claus on there
done with crayons and it says here Joe
I'm sorry for all the bad things I did I
keep this box every single place I've
ever lived I store different things in
here oh and here's look there's ET my
grandmother was an artist art was always
something that she did my mother is an
incredible artist and
um I'm okay
hey thanks for having me GQ I loved
sharing my 10 Essentials right now and
don't forget you gotta watch power book
4 Force September 1st not stops
[Music]